recording in progress
bonjour
conferences press
um
so if you have questions you might you
may want to raise your hand right now so
i can uh
come up with a list for question period
don't convocate
first i'm pleased to provide you with
the
latest data on vaccination
as of january 30th which is just
therefore last sunday 85
of all canadians had received a first
dose
79
of all canadians of all ages had
received two doses and among those
eligible
50
had received an additional booster dose
which is an increase of 5
compared to the earlier week
also nerdy nearly 55 percent of children
age 5 to 11
had received at least one dose that's an
increase of 2 percent compared to the
earlier week
i obviously encourage all parents to get
their eligible children vaccinated
the health canada website actually has
lots of useful information on pediatric
vaccination
including a series of ask the doctor
videos which can help parents us parents
make the best informed decision for our
children
[Music]
covet 19 pandemic has reinforced the
importance of nurses in our health
system
now more than ever is a time to ensure
their perspective the perspectives of
nurses and their experiences have to be
more integrated in our decision making
that is why last week health canada
began a process to hire a chief nursing
officer the successful candidate will
not only represent the interests of
nurses at the national level but will
also contribute to the important
healthcare policy work that health
canada needs to do ongoing
i encourage all qualified candidates to
apply and i look very much forward to
greeting the new canadian nursing
officer later this spring
foreign
case counts have been decreasing in
recent weeks but hospitalizations and
icu remain at a very high level
it therefore continues to be important
to limit the spread of the virus as much
as possible we have to remain prudent
individual efforts that are that is the
efforts of every one of us including the
layering of personal protections are
helping to slow transmission and help
also mitigate severe illness across
canada
i'll say it again we'll say it again
vaccination is one of the most effective
ways to protect ourselves against severe
disease and transmission of copying 19.
if you have not already done so i urge
you to take this important step to
protect yourself and to protect the
health of those around you
enormous
hospitalizations
this winter unprecedented numbers of
people in canada have been infected with
the highly contagious omicron variant
though declining
daily new case counts averaging over 10
000 daily together with other indicators
of covin-19 disease activity including
test positivity rt or the effective
reproduction number and wastewater
surveillance trends indicate ongoing
widespread activity across the country
presently severe illness trends are
elevated or still rising in many areas
of the country
up to february the second
an average of over 10 000 people with
cover 19 were being treated in hospitals
each day including over 1 100 in
intensive care and over 140 deaths were
reported daily
as we continue to take measures to
mitigate the impact of covet 19 and
protect our heavily strained health
system experts are learning more every
day about the effectiveness of covid19
vaccines
at the same time we are moving ever
closer to more and better treatments
these advancements will help lighten the
load that so many of us have been
carrying in the space between us and
through the difficult sacrifices we've
made
since the outset of covet 19 vaccination
programs canada's national advisory
committee on immunization or nasty
and health authorities across the
country have continued to monitor
vaccine safety and effectiveness data
what the latest data show is that while
two doses of cova-19 vaccine offer
reasonably good protection against
severe disease receiving an mrna booster
dose offers superior protection keeping
more people out of hospital or
preventing more deaths
in general data show that protection
against hospitalizations
is over 90
with an mrna booster dose which is 15 to
40 higher effectiveness than with just
two doses
there are many benefits of being fully
up to date with cover 19 vaccines across
all eligible age groups protection
ranges from the smaller and shorter
duration against infection
through a somewhat larger reduction in
symptomatic illness to strong protection
against severe outcomes
given the very large number of canadians
with a confirmed or apparent infection
during the omicron surge in particular
it is also important to highlight that
previously infected people benefit from
starting or completing their covet 19
vaccination
hence for the best possible protection
against severe illness now and going
forwards
health authorities continue to strongly
recommend up-to-date kelvin 19
vaccination for all eligible people
including for those who have had a
covert 19 infection
today nasty is releasing updated
recommendations on suggested intervals
for administration of boosted doses for
those who have been previously infected
notably nasty suggests that an mrna
booster be given at least six months
after the previous dose or three months
following infection whichever is longer
however as no vaccine is 100 effective
it is important for everyone to continue
to use personal protective measures such
as wearing a good quality snug fitting
mask avoids eating crowding and
improving ventilation in indoor spaces
for the many hard-won advancements that
would not have been possible without the
collective efforts of countless
canadians thank you
disease activity including test
positivity
is
these advancements will help lighten the
load that so many of us have been
carrying
in the space between us and through the
difficult sacrifices we've made
they
programmed 19 vaccinations
advisory committee on
immunizations and health authorities
across the country
have continued to monitor
safety
and effectiveness
protection against severe diseases
is 100 effective it is important for
everyone to continue to use personal
protective measures such as wearing a
good quality snug fitting masks
thank
so now we'll uh go to questions you know
the drill one question one follow-up uh
list
um
go ahead
[Music]
um
[Music]
provinces are still seeing this problem
where there isn't been a drop can they
also be expecting
a kiss giant answer thank you for the
questions
has been really closely monitoring the
epidemiological
data as the field and everyone is
prepared to adjust public health
measures
everyone's done everyone's tired so am i
i think really it is important to
continue with the vaccination effort
increase
when responsible everybody has
is
in certain cases reinstate some measures
it's difficult to predict what will
happen if we loosen some of the rules
at this point
is
and how contagious it is
how much does it resist the vaccinations
it's interesting to see
the omicron
[Music]
have not had uh same experiences
questions
actually
it is
the indications seem to be that the two
visions
contagious
in the effectiveness of vaccines
of course every variant requires us to
maintain our collective
vaccination first and foremost
m
merci uh rafi bhuji canyon cbc news
europe
ruffy
sorry was i muted still
okay you're good
okay thanks uh my first questions for
minister d khloe you promised 140
million rapid tests would be delivered
to the provinces in january we know some
are reporting numbers that are much
lower than that and so where are the
rapid tests
thank you so let me first provide a
a higher overview for those that
maybe didn't follow the whole uh context
so we
know that with even prior to omicron the
use of rapid tests was uh not only
under
estimated but the value
i think was probably misunderstood and
that's why for some months and a large
number of months in fact in 2020 and
2021 there was a
relatively modest demand for rapid tests
on the part of provinces and territories
that's not a blame it's just a statement
when
we
started to see
christmas coming uh
early in december we
worked with provinces and territories
and multiplied by five
the average number of rapid debt that
had been delivered to them prior to
december which is what was about seven
million rapid tests multiplied by phi so
we were able
relatively quickly and perhaps
surprisingly for some move to 35 million
rapid test delivered in december and
then with omicron obviously
we saw quickly a larger much larger
demand for rapid tests not only in
canada but internationally so we
committed to delivering 140 million
rapid tests so multiplying by four
compared to december the number of added
tests delivered to provinces and
territories in january
now the remarkable
news is that we were able to secure
and have 140 million rapid tests arrive
by the end of january in canada that was
obviously an immense struggle we were
competing with many other countries
which has which had identical uh knees
and requests so despite these ex immense
immense pressure on supply chains we
were able to have 140 million rapid
tests by the end of january that is by
january 31st
the majority of these tests have been
delivered prior to the end of january to
provinces and territories many of them
have been delivered since the since
monday since january 31st but there are
more tests arriving to provinces and
territories in the next few days so that
at the end as we have promised 140
million rapid tests will have been
delivered i i will end by saying that we
took stock of
that outcome and the challenges related
to it with my colleagues health
ministers just yesterday yesterday we
had a meeting all of us together
to uh to see where we are you know to to
celebrate the arrival of these millions
of relatives but also to recognize that
we need a lot more predictability
ongoing with the actual timing of those
rapid tests as the situation evolves
thank you and my follow-up is for dr tam
some provinces like saskatchewan and
alberta are moving quickly to remove
restrictions despite high
hospitalization rates is that happening
too quickly
i think the province is in the best
position to judge that because they have
different health system capacity so it
is a very difficult um
balance
to to do
so i think
you know that that's the challenge ahead
of the provincial
response
i do think that
prior to
vaccinations prior to
getting some more treatments
and of course some immunity afforded by
omicron
that balance was very very difficult to
achieve
and i am you know optimistic
that it will be
come easier to achieve that better
balance however we know how fragile
health systems are
so i think
at the provincial level they will have
to um do their own
assessment of that um it's more it's
difficult at the federal level
to be able to make that call
oh
[Music]
uh
we
uh
it's a matter of finding the balance the
right balance
um
foreign
yes
you know a six month booster shot for
the rest of uh
to monitor the situation
but protection does decrease
population-wise
over time
what will happen in the
exactly future uh potentially adaptive
values
that might be adapted to these
effects
about vaccinating canadians in canada
about vaccinations
even specifically with respect
new
to
the
we're not prepared to
offer vaccination the world over this
could be a problem
not
oh hi thanks for taking our questions
and good morning minister to khloe the
toronto star has a report this morning
on the delay in january shipment of
rapid test provinces the paper found
that some atlantic provinces got upwards
of 85 of their quota while others with
much higher prevalence of active covid
have half or even one third of their
quota so if your government is guided by
evidence why is your department giving
rapid tests to provinces that don't need
them as badly
well thank you and that's a an important
question i answered i'm sure you
understood the answer didn't i answer uh
earlier on the broader context now the
140 million
tests arrived in canada the fact that
this represented approximately 20 times
more rapid tests than the average over
2021 so i believe you have heard that
answer now why is the
why are the percentages to individual
provinces and territories variable
across canada well that depends on
all sorts of things and i'll just
mention one it depends in part on the
specific
demands and conditions which provinces
are asking us to deliver those tests
with so just to give you an example
these rapid tests come in different
packages
different types different providers and
therefore we want as much as possible
we're obviously not perfect we want to
meet those uh demands
and expectations of different provinces
and territories and that means that that
need that means that
some of those rapid tests are delivered
more quickly because of the
size of the boxes and so on to some
specific provinces and territories but
overall we're obviously extremely
mindful of the importance of treating
all provinces and territories equitably
and that's why for instance we are now
proceeding with a per capita allocation
of rapid tests to provinces and
territories that was done differently in
2021 and we know that because of that
some privacy and territories got more
rapid tests because they were asking
more of those rapid tests but now we
believe that
across canada all canadians where
regardless of where they live should
have access to the same
availability of rapid tests wherever
they live
thank you and uh minister duklow the
southern manitoba's grand chief says
that health canada lost an order of
rapid tests that the first nations had
placed with your department last
september
indigenous services canada says it was
handled by health canada and this
morning they said they're still looking
into my tuesday question of what
happened here the grand chief said that
this would never happen to a province
and he sees systemic racism here
he reordered the tests in november and
they're coming three months later i'm
wondering what you make of this
situation
well from what i hear
from you that's obviously not acceptable
and will therefore look into this and
understand my officials have already
started to do so but i'll make sure that
the
greater effort and focus and is provided
to that obviously working with
indigenous services
canada minister i do is not only
responsible for that department as a but
as a former minister of health she's
also extremely mindful of the importance
of providing indigenous communities the
support that they need including as you
said rapid test deliveries
canada next question from canada
can you hear us now
wait yes we can hear you we okay mr
miraculous
vaccinations
uh
is
um
foreign
yes
[Music]
do you think the federal government has
a role to play in freeing up
[Music]
um
does the federal government need
leave
rachel gilmore from global news
to continue along with your friends okay
rachel rachel
are you there
hey sorry can you hear me yes
awesome thank you so much um so i had a
quick question uh for the doctors
specifically i'm wondering if you have
any advice for residents of the downtown
core in ottawa obviously there are a
number of individuals who speak as if
they are unvaccinated it's unclear what
their vaccination status is but they are
opponents to mandatory vaccinations
should residents of the downtown core be
taking extra precautions as they
navigate their daily lives with these
protesters around
i think for the question the first thing
is of course follow the advice of ottawa
public health they have the
pulse on the ground in terms of what's
going on from a public health
perspective
and they would issue advice as needed
but of course we all know the layers of
protection that everybody can take
depending on the epidemiology or indeed
environment that
people are
living or
working or existing in so i think for
sure
you know make sure everyone is well
empowered to
wear masks and
be able to
use all those layers of protection that
we talk about every day to try and
protect themselves but um
i think if you're well vaccinated
you're wearing a mask and you're
conscious of
you know where you're moving or
gathering and take extra precautions you
can certainly
uh reduce your risk of infection but
there's still quite a high level of um
transmission going on right now in most
parts of the country even though the
cases are coming down so
no matter where you are i think
this advice
applies
thank you and uh just for my follow-up i
was wondering um if you folks have a
message for your fellow healthcare
workers at this time because we have
seen directives in toronto specifically
telling healthcare workers they may not
want to walk to and from work in their
health care attire um unless they become
a target of those who oppose
you know public health measures and
we've also seen reports that citizens in
downtown ottawa who try to follow the
advice you just mentioned of wearing
masks also find themselves harassed so
do you have any advice for a the
individuals who are being harassed for
following public health advice and b
a message for health care workers who
might be finding this whole situation
disheartening
yes so i think
we need to really be grateful and
appreciate our health workers and our
public health workers because they've
been working day and night for over two
years
to try and keep all of us safe
and it's unacceptable any kind of hate
any kind of violence is it should not be
uh tolerated um
protests of one thing and it should be
done as peacefully
uh should be done peacefully and these
are the very people who are trying to
help
not only to protect people against
kelvin 19 but for
to to to support the community and all
sorts of health
issues
if you had an accident if you
need surgical
interventions
if you've got need cancer treatment so
all these workers need to be able to
have a safe passage to work
and i think that's
critically important
um i know that
the minister may have something to say
of course
um having uh policies
that essentially lays out the fact that
harassment of healthcare workers is
completely unacceptable
thank you not only is it completely
unacceptable for the reasons that
dr tam
mentioned but we are all aware i believe
that
the house of commons passed and
parliament passed a law
just earlier in 2021
putting severe criminal sanctions for
those
that are intimidating
threatening
health care workers we are immensely
grateful and to them and we depend on
them and in fact we're all in this
together we depend on them for the
reason that dr tam said not only are
they looking after
thousands of canadians being
hospitalized because of kobe 19 but also
looking after many other thousands of
canadians that every day require
hospital and other health care
services so
unacceptable and criminal and because of
that i would invite all
health care workers
to report any such incident to their
police force
okay so we have a hard stop at 10 30 and
i just saw laura osmond's
hand come up so we'll go with the last
one for uh for the road laura
thank you so much for taking my question
i wanted to ask about vaccine mandates
of course some provinces saying they
want to do with away with vaccine
passports for example and a lot of
people are wondering if there's any
value in them left given just how
transmissible
omicron is even for the vaccinated and
so i'm wondering if the doctors can
weigh in on the value of vaccine
passports at this point
yes um it's theresa 10 maybe i'll start
we actually
looking at
a whole range of public health
measures and policies together with the
province and territories trying to get a
handle from my colleagues the chief
medical officers on the ground as to
what the path forwards might be for a
whole suite of these measures
um i think um vaccine mandates of course
primarily are related to
uh provincial jurisdiction and um i i do
think these
measures should be evaluated going
forwards but for sure we we're
reiterating that vaccines are extremely
important particularly in reducing
serious outcomes but as i've said in my
opening remarks
the protection against infection is
reduced
certainly with two doses it doesn't
really protect you against infection but
three doses can certainly protect you
for a period of time
against infections but
really really good protection against
serious outcomes and our ultimate goal i
think in this country is to reduce
serious outcomes and mortality
which vaccines
uh fundamentally
a
foundational
tool or layer protection that
i think everyone needs
so how do we
make sure that we optimize and maximize
vaccine vaccinations is something that
is of collective
interest and a topic of critical
discussion right now um i don't i think
i think jurisdictions are in slightly
different spaces in terms of their
uh current situation um so i i do think
that all policies uh need to be exam
re-examined over time and this is uh one
of them as well but for now you know of
course vaccinations are
uh really important in our
ability to manage the uh negative impact
of this current wave i think
what we do need to do
going forwards as we emerge of the hong
kong
wave is to recognize that this virus is
not going to disappear
and we need to be able to address the
ongoing presence of the saskov2 virus
in a more sustainable way
and we need to continue and the virus
will continue to evolve so we need to
also continue to evolve our measures
recognizing that further waves will
occur
some will actually be quite severe or
disruptive and we need to be ready for
them but we do need to have more longer
term sustained approaches and capacity
building
so that we're not uh in crisis mode all
the time as we fight
uh the this virus so
i think i'm looking forward to
that kind of a lot slightly longer term
um discussion with my colleagues
thanks so much dr tam
please
let me add very briefly sorry to
interrupt to the wise words of of dr tam
the key
objective of a vaccine mandate and we do
this at the federal level is to protect
protect individuals to protect people
by
through vaccinations so vaccination
mandates primary objective is to protect
people when they
move and work in in life it's not to
punish them
we vaccine mandates are not there to
punish people they obviously create an
incentive which is a second order
objective and that incentive does indeed
also work at the federal level as we
have noticed 99 percent of public
servants have uh have vaccinated
themselves so they have protected
themselves against the virus so
obviously they do that to protect their
own health
uh which is the key objective but they
are also incentivized to do that through
a a vaccine mandate i would end
by saying that
as dr tam
mentioned this is going to be an ongoing
conversation but uh vaccination as we
said earlier
is an incredible an incredible tool
which science and scientists have given
us about a year ago which i which we've
had the fortune of using with great
success over the last year which we know
is going to continue to be an important
tool as we move forward
thank you so much on that note i was
hoping to ask you
minister to close well about
travel mandates and what conversations
are happening in terms of
at what point
can the federal government start to
think about stepping that down from sort
of a scientific perspective in terms of
of
maintaining protection without
inhibiting people unnecessarily
i'm sorry i think i missed part of your
question and i apologize for having you
know asking you to repeat again not at
all um i'm just wondering at what point
the federal government expects to start
stepping down
vaccine mandates for travel
um given some of the things you just
said and what dr tan said about
um
you know
the protection against transmission with
two doses
well the short answer
well i think we have an issue with the
mr duclosa
signal
okay the so
sorry about that
um
laura you
won't get your answer and maybe dr tam
or dr new you wish to answer
about the travel mandates
yeah um it's teresa tam so i think
as with all policies and there's
actually a building on my uh answer to
the previous
question is the border measures are
layers of protection and so
i think some of the abilities for us to
shift those
measures
and indeed to facilitate travel
particularly for um
for vaccinated individuals at the moment
is dependent on how the domestic
epidemiology looks like and the
healthcare capacity as well as what's
happening globally
we're monitoring that very closely
obviously
at the domestic level
case is a bit beginning to come down and
hospitalizations
still going up in many areas so
it's it's quite difficult to sort of
reduce those measures when that's the
situation
um of of the
ability to
cope with any kind of ins additional
introduction but at the same time we
need to begin to plan forwards
for when this particular wave um
you know recedes
and um
be ready i think i think that the whole
concept is
we we do need to get back to some um
you know normalcy
um and that includes our border measures
and policies
and
use the innovation and the tools that we
have
to try and enable safe travel
um
and
you know traveling outside
also depends on looking at the uh
epidemiologic information globally right
now
uh the omaha wave is going strong
so i think that
absolutely has to be uh reevaluated in
the days and weeks to come
it's dr new uh the only other thing i
would add is that you know certainly the
issue you raised uh is is important for
canada but i think it's also a worldwide
issue and if you look at the whole the
world health organization and the
international health regulations that's
something i think that
needs to be looked at because certainly
there's a balance between what we call a
containing public health threats
obviously in this case a global pandemic
but at the same time not unduly
restricting a travel and trade and that
was uh one of the key points that was in
the international health regulations
which came out of the sarsa situation
many years ago so i think
not just canada but i think collectively
around the world and with the world
health organization that's something we
need to look at as we move forward
[Music]
please
you